[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ الهندي يحيى جبايه في مدينه
دربا في جنوب افريقيا لاسره هاجرت من
مدينه كوجرات الهنديه للتجاره منذ
الاربعينيات من القرن الماضي ولم يحل نظام
التمييز العنصري انذاك بينها وبين انشاء
مدارس للقران الكريم وتحفيظ ابنائها
وابناء الجاليه الهنديه فحفظ هو وثلاثه من
اخوته القران الكريم
والدي كان يهتم بالقران من صغارنا
اليس كمثل جدي كان رجل عادي يعني كان تاجر
نحن عشره اولاد الحمد لله وثلاثه منا قد
حفظنا القران عندنا بلغنا
خمسه من عمرنا والدي كان
تعلمنا الاسوار الجزء عما كل هذا ثم سوار
الكبيره مثل سليمان ياسين سوره الكهف
ثم بدانا بالحفظنا سنه عشره تقريبا
والحمد لله قد حفلنا من القران
بدانا عند والده وكان ما كان عنده مدرسه
عند البيت في البدايه ثم وكان شديد علينا
في الحفظ فما استطعت ثم تحولنا الى صديقه
اسمه
كاري سلو محمد سلو
فحفلنا بعد جزء عنده
ثم تركت هذا المدرسه
ودخلنا المدرسه الحكوميه
في هذا السنوات كان صعب ان ندرس في
المدرسه ونحفظ القران ايضا
فكملنا سبع سنوات في المدرسه حكوميه ثم
اخرجنا والده من المدرسه
الى مدرسه معهد النور هو كان مدرس هناك
يعني المدرس هناك
فذهبنا الى مدرسه معهد النور الاسلاميه في
مدينه اسمه بريطانيا
جلست هناك خمس سنوات
يحفظون القران نحفظ القران
فانا كان طالب
يعني
كنت العب كثيرا
ما كنت مركز يعني فبعد خمس سنوات اخرجني
والدي من المدرسه
ولا انت
بتجلس عندي وتحفظ عندي كلما كان اذهب تذهب
معي
فالحمد لله بعد سنه كامل
وكنت ثمانيه عشر كنت استمع الى الشيخ
مشاريع الافاسي
لكن
الاحسن كان والدي
يعني قراءته كان ممتاز جدا ما شاء الله
كان جميله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يا ايها الذين امنوا استعينوا بالصبر والص
[موسيقى]
ان الله مع الصابرين
ولا تقولوا
لمن يقتل في سبيل الله
اموات
بل اح
ياء ولكن لا تش
عرون الحمد لله المسلمين عندنا حريه يعني
بديننا
لكن اظن بعد سنوات برات
كثنهم منهم لا يهتمون بالقران كثير يعني
كما كان في الماضي لكن عندنا مدارس كثيره
طلاب يحفظون القران يخرجون كل سنوات مئه
لكن بعد ان يخرجون
اظن
يعني
ما يبشون على على كان
الكثير منهم نسي ما حفظوا
لكن الحمد لله
عندنا الكره كثيره خصوصا في مدينه
كثير مدارس هناك
يدرسون عشره روايه عشره
ومقامات لابد ان يعطيك يعني يوميا وقت
معين ان تجلس
وتراجع الذي قد حفت
ووالدي كان ينصحنا كثير
قال لنا اذا تريد ان
يكون القران مضبوط عندك
تحاول ان تقرا في صلاه النوافل
في صلاه التراويح
حاول ان ان تكمل ختم يعني في رمضان
بهذا ان شاء الله سيكون
لكن لابد يعني كل يوم يوميا
ان يكون وقت خاص للقران
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
[موسيقى]
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
[موسيقى]
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعد يحيى جبايه من الجيل الثالث من مسلم
جنوب افريقيا دون فك الارتباط بمواطنهم
الاصليه فالثقافه الاسيويه الهنديه منها
خاصه تبدو في جميع تفاصيل حياتهم كما
تنعكس على المساجد والمدارس والدورانيه
التي تنتشر بالعشرات في المدن والقرى حيث
تفخر العائلات المهاجره بحفظ ابنائها
للقران الكريم ايجاده واتقانا
اظن كل مساجد في مدارس
نا القران
نسمى مكتب
خاصه من ساعه الثالثه الى ساعه خامسه يعني
بعد الوقت المدرسه الحكوميه
والحمد لله
نرى ان كثير من الاولاد ما شاء الله بدا
ان ان
نعلم كيف قراءه
كيف يقعون القران من هذه المدارس
والمساجد الحمد لله نشاط
اظن اكثر من اكثر صلوات الحمد لله في
رمضان المساجد
الجو جميل نعم الناس
نشاط
يختمون القران يوميا
في بعض المساجد
يخدمون القران في صلاه التراويح في ليله
واحده
فبعد ان كملنا بحفظ القران عند والده
هو انصحني ان
ابدا بدراسه
اما لغه عربيه او اسلاميه
لكن اراد
اراد
ان نخرج من بلاد جنوب افريقيا
الى بلاد ثاني اي بلد
وقال ان
في البدايه في البدايه
نريد ان اذهب الى مغرب
لكن
كان بعد اسباب ما
ذهبنا
فوالدي قال لي ان اذهب الى يمن
الحمد لله ذهبنا هناك جلسنا هناك خمس
سنوات في سنه اولى درسنا اللغه العربيه
الحمد لله
والباقي من اربعه سنوات
درسنا الدروس الاسلاميه مثل الفقه على
مذهب امام ابو حنيفه
وبعد كتب في تجويد
وعقيده
الحمد لله وجدنا ان
اليمن ما شاء الله الناس طيبين
وحياتهم يعني بسيطه لكن
احسن شيء ان ان البيئه عن الاسلاميه ذهبنا
الى المدرسه
اسمه دار المصطفى في مدينه تريم في حضرموت
وسكنا هناك
مع 400 طلاب في كل غرفه تسعه طلاب الحمد
لله كل واحد على سريره
والترتيب اليوم كان كان صعب شويه في
البدايه ثم تعودنا عليه
هم كان مركز على ثلاثه اشياء
في العلم والدعوه
والاسلام والاصلاح
يعني يومنا كان يبدا من الساعه الثالث
اظنه
ايوه الساعه الثالثه
فهناك يعني اذكار في اخر الليل ثم صلاه
الفجر
ثم كان عندنا
ثلاثه ثلاثه دروس
وبعد اثنين كان فطور ثم الثالث ثم كان وقت
الفاضي الى صلاه الظهر بعد صلاه الظهر كان
عندنا حزب حزب القران نحن جلسنا في حلقات
كل حلقه يقرا ممكن جزئين ثلاثه اجزاء
ونختم القران
ركزت كثير على سلاح النفس
والاهتمام بالصلاه
لان البيئه هكذا هناك يعني تشوف الاولاد
ممكن خمس سته
لا يحتمل بس بصلاه الفرائض حتى النوافل
اشوف بعدهم في الصباح قبل ان يدخل المدرسه
ويروح للمسجد يصلي صلاه
ركعتين ثم يروح للمدرسه في القراءه
ليس كثير
لانه
درست الاكثر اكثر عند والدي لكن زد في
تجويد في علم التجويد نعم درسنا كتب
كتبين للشيخ
الاحياء الغوثاني
شيخ يحيى الغوثاني نعم الف كتاب في تجويد
فدرسنا هذا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
امن الرسول
[موسيقى]
بما
انزل اليه من ربه والمؤمنون
[موسيقى]
كل امن بالله ومل
ائكته وكتبه ورسله
لا نفرق بين احد
من رسله
وقالوا سمعنا
واطعنا
غفرانك ربنا
واليك المصير
لا يكلف الله نفسا الا وسعها
لها ما كسبت وعليها ما اكتسبت
ربنا لا تؤاخذنا
ان نسينا
او اخطانا
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا
عصرا كما حملته على الذين من قبلنا
ربنا ولا
تحملنا ما لا طاقه لنا به
واعف عنا
واغفر لنا
وارحمنا
انت مولانا
فانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
المسلمون في دين
اصلهم اكثر من الهند في باكستانيين
قليل منهم
اصلهم من افريقيا من جنوب افريقيا
لكن
العدد زاد
في سنوات لان
بدا
يمنون مدارس في
القريه المختلفه
الذي يعيشون هناك
جنوب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]